surely considering is not for everyone  though let me share the number one  reason based on my experience as a  former mckinsey consultant why i believe  consulting is a great experience for  young graduates especially in strategy  consulting firms like mckinsey bcg or  bane team sizes are quite small so  typically only two to four people on a  team as a junior you are one of these  two to four people this means that from  the beginning you will have a  significant amount of responsibility if  you cannot do the job it will be very  difficult for the other team members to  completely cover all of your  responsibilities of course this can be  quite challenging but this is also what  the steep learning curve is all about  you will grow significantly  professionally and personally exactly  due to this environment let me know  about your experiences in the comments